c'est une question qui mérite d'être
posée à chaque conflit jusqu'à quel
point faut-il présenter des images de la
guerre comme cette vidéo qui présente un
homme aspiré par un tir de mortier
ou attention des images qui pourraient
vous choquer comme celle-ci publié sur
la page d'accueil du new york times où
l'on peut voir une famille dont deux
enfants retrouvés morts avec leur balise
alors qu'il tentait de fuir les
bombardements russes peut-être
cette volonté de faire
quelque chose
la professeur colette brin estime que ce
genre de photos chocs permettent à la
fois à d'illustrés la dure réalité de la
guerre sur le terrain et aussi de
contrecarrer la désinformation temps
chili russe que les ukrainiens c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut utiliser qu'il
faut pas donc il faut pas abuser ce
genre de photos là parce que
ça fera beaucoup puis il faut pas
banaliser ce genre de violence et de
nombreuses photos sont passés à
l'histoire comme celle qu'on a
tristement surnommée la petite fille au
napalm lors de la guerre du vietnam où
cette photo du petit alien curdy trois
ans découverts sur une plage turc
inanimé sur le sable face contre terre
janvier ou qui est déjà là
le photo journaliste de radio-canada
ivanoh demers a couvert plusieurs crises
la publication de photos ou même
tragique a sa raison d'être selon lui
les images sont très dur et il faut les
faire et après ce faux les envoyer et il
ya toute une chaîne de décision qui plus
tard des gens peuvent décider s'ils vont
les publient au port ironiquement de
plus en plus les photographes de toute
façon mais tes photos sur leur faim est
agréable
et même s'ils sont en petit nombre sur
le terrain le travail des reporters
comme des photojournalistes s'avère plus
qu'essentiel à l'ère des réseaux sociaux
ici gabriel pro radio canada montréal